- Hello Believe Nation, we're
going to continue the experiment
of my favorite top ten rules to success.
Basically, all the videos that we've had
from the past month, the top tens,
pulling out what my favorite rule was
and mashing them together just for you.
Let me know what you think,
and as always, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well, enjoy.
(loud rushing)
♫ Woah
♫ I used to rule the world
♫ Seas would rise when I gave the word
♫ Now in the morning I sleep
- [Narrator] London,
just before Christmas,
the soaring melodies, the
thumping beat of the music
and the quirky charisma of
lead singer Chris Martin
had the crowd on it's feet.
- We rely more on enthusiasm
than actual skill.
(rock music)
Whatever you do, do it enthusiastically
and people will like it more.
♫ Come back and sing to me
I can't dance like Usher,
I can't sing like Beyonce,
I can't write songs like Elton John
♫ Come on and sing it out
♫ Now
But we can do the best
we can with what we got.
♫ Come on and sing it out
♫ For me
And so that's what we
do, we just go for it.
(whooshing)
- I really get motivated
when people tell me
it'll never happen, it's like, you know.
I mean it happens to me all
the time in my business,
you got to understand guys,
I got to reinvent myself
every record, so that means
every three to six months
I got to find myself again,
because the last record,
or the new record,
is not as big as the last record.
(speaking in foreign language)
(laughter)
But you guys don't understand,
I got a guy that's sitting in an office
that hasn't been to a club
(speaking in foreign language)
(audience laughing)
He don't understand none of that.
Telling me what a hit record is.
(laughter)
You know?
So you got to be able
to stick to your gut,
stick to what you believe in,
understand your worth, and go, okay,
well this is where you
build an infrastructure.
At least in my business,
we build our own team,
our own one stop shop
where if someone says no,
we don't think it is, say don't worry,
we'll check back in in a
month, and we'll see who,
you know man, it'll just happen,
it'll go, oh that'll never work.
And in a month, (speaking
in foreign language)
You know this is really
starting to sound like a hit.
(laughter)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Interviewer] So yeah.
- So that motivates me.
That to me is what makes
me get up in the morning
and go, what's next?
(whooshing)
- What were you like as a child?
- I was a combination of
reclusive and obsessed
with what I wanted to do.
When I was two, I was
sitting in front of the TV
drawing Fred Flintstones,
- Yeah.
- And Woody Peckers, and at
age seven I'm running around
like a crazy person doing voices,
but at the same time I would
try to make animated films
and try to figure out exactly
how that art form worked.
- When did you do your first cartoon?
How old were you and what was it?
- I was in seventh grade.
It was called Space
Pirates, it was terrible.
(slam)
- I, as you know, I was
a bouncer for many years.
I remember coming home one
night after a big fight,
and I run up to the kitchen, I get ice,
and my hand's swollen,
just another day at work.
And I was feeling like, just bummed
about the fact that I
was still doing this job
after all this time.
At that one moment, I
was like, why are people,
what's up, why do people
have so much anger?
Why is this my daily life to
suppress everybody's anger
or check everybody's anger
that comes into a giant
3,000 person nightclub?
- Mhmm.
- And my father, it was so simple,
but my father said, "you
know Vin, I've traveled
around the world. I've been to India,
I've been to Russia, I've been to China,
I've been all through South America,
and I've realized something."
I said, "what?"
He said, "people by and
large, are good people."
Sounded pretty simple,
and yet it meant so much.
And if you look at my Facebook page,
or if you look at the way
that all that positive energy,
I don't think there's a page
in the world, in history,
that harbors as much positive energy
as one would see on this Facebook page.
And it's really--
- It's what you put out, too.
- And it's really that.
- Right.
- I say that because,
if you believe that in your heart,
and not everybody watching
this can say that,
or is ready to say that, or is comfortable
with themselves enough to say that,
but if you really believe in your heart
that people by and large are good people,
it affects the way that
you address the world.
As you see, post in and post out,
I address a world that, in my soul,
I feel is comprised of good people.
(slam)
- Yeah, I've always been driven, you know,
even at a young age,
all I ever wanted to do
was become a footballer, a soccer star.
And that was my only ambition.
I know it's different
these days with kids,
you know, obviously there's
fame, there's fortune,
and it might be easy for me to say that
because obviously I've done
very well out of the game,
but I'd still be playing this game
even if I wasn't being paid for it.
Not that I don't want
- Mission accomplished.
- To be paid for it.
(audience laughing)
(interviewer laughing)
But I still would be playing this sport.
(slam)
- The notion that we
are not enough is a lie.
And I think more young
people need to know that.
That like, when you have that thought
that you're not enough,
that that's based on a lie
that somebody said to you, or a lie
that somebody did to you.
Like, somebody said or
did something to you
to make you feel like you're not enough,
and that's not true.
That you are everything
that you need to be,
you have everything that you need to have
to be the person that you're meant to be
and to be the best version
of who you're meant to be.
It may mean that you
have to work really hard,
and it may mean that you
have to ask for help,
but you are perfectly blessed.
You know, you are exactly
who you're supposed to be
to be joyful in this life.
So don't be afraid to work hard,
and don't be afraid to ask for help
so you can get there,
because that's your truth.
(slam)
- You have to be authentic.
I mean, you've got no
hope if you try to pretend
to be Reed Hastings, or Mark
Zuckerberg, or Bill Gates,
or whoever you want to
think you're CEOs are
that you've met, you know, that is crazy.
And you got to really get
comfortable with yourself,
your strengths and weaknesses.
People are inspired by
authenticity, and I'm just surprised
how many people feel like they're acting,
and or try to act.
And you may be a really quiet
person, and that's fine,
but if you have that fierce will,
that desire for the institution,
the company to be great,
and your own role in that is secondary,
and you authentically express
that in whatever ways you do,
then you'll be greatly accepted, okay?
And so that's all it
takes is to be authentic
and not try to be something else,
and to fundamentally care, at your core,
about what's good for the company.
And if everybody knows,
and you act in the notion
of what's good as best as
your judgment can tell,
what's good for the
company, they will see that.
And people will follow you,
and they won't be cynical.
It's when you hide things,
it's when you pretend.
(slam)
- Everybody has their own
sense of accomplishment,
you know, some it's
opening weekend box office,
or winning Academy Awards.
To me, it is being in
an audience anonymously
and watching people watch my movies,
and seeing how we're entertaining people.
The first true experience
I ever had of that
was about five days
after Toy Story came out.
It took four years for
me to make Toy Story,
all of us at Pixar, and I
was flying with my family
and we were changing planes in
the Dallas For Worth Airport.
I got off the plane, and
there was a little boy,
about four years old, with his mother,
and he was holding a
Woody the Cowboy doll.
And it's the first time I'd
seen one of my characters
outside of Pixar, and I was so stunned,
my boy's, "Dad, look, look, look."
The look on his face, he
couldn't wait to show his father,
who was getting off the plane, his toy.
And I realized at that
moment that that character
that I, with the help of
everybody at Pixar, created
over four years, no longer
belong to me, it belonged to him.
And to be honest, it's
so much in my memory
the look on that little boy's face,
I think about that little
boy every single day
working at Pixar, and
that's why we do what we do.
(slam)
- Well, certainly every product we do
is absolutely as capable
as it can possibly be.
You know, there's no holding back.
The people at Microsoft
come into work every day
building the best products they can.
And they're very proud.
You know, you go out, go into schools
and see how kids are using this stuff.
Go and ask people about
how their jobs have changed
because of the personal computer.
You know,
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- We're sitting there,
listening to our customers
saying how they'd like
to make things better.
So, we do absolutely our best job,
and in fact, that's why we've
been successful, you know.
Anybody who holds back in this business
isn't going to be around for long,
because this is a business
where you always have to be
moving at a very rapid pace.
(slam)
- As yourself, what if no one
ever bought any of my work?
What if I'm never going to sell a book,
or publish a book, or a short story?
Are you going to continue to write?
And if the answer is
yes, because I have to,
then yeah, you are a writer.
And whether you'll sell
or not, I can't know,
but if there's stories in
you that have to get out,
you want to put them down on paper,
whether you ever get the
affirmation of a contract
or a book in your hand, or
being on the best seller list,
if you still have to tell your stories,
then you're a writer.
If you can give it up, then
it probably would be an act
of sanity to learn accounting
or something like that.
(slam)
- In the long history of the world,
only a few generations
have been granted the role
of defending freedom in
it's hour of maximum danger.
I do not shrink from this
responsibility, I welcome it.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
I do not believe that any
of us would exchange places
with any other people
or any other generation.
The energy, the faith, the devotion
which we bring to this endeavor.
We'll light our country
and all who serve it,
and the glow from that fire
can surely light the world.
And so my fellow Americans,
ask not what your country can do for you,
ask what you can do for your country.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
My fellow citizens of the world,
ask not what America will do for you,
but what together we can
do for the freedom of man.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Finally, whether you
are citizens of America,
or citizens of the world,
ask of us here the same
high standards of strength and sacrifice
which we ask of you.
With a good conscience
our only sure reward,
with history the final judge of our deeds,
let us go forth to lead the land we love,
asking His blessing and His help,
but knowing that here on Earth,
God's work must truly be our own.
(slam)
- I see myself as a pioneer in the game.
I see Drake as a pioneer in the game,
people like Lil Wayne,
there's only certain people
who really come and
define your generation,
other than being a part
of your generation.
And it's cool to be a part of it as well,
but this is how I see myself, as a leader
and somebody who changes
things and doesn't just follow.
(slam)
- So you've sort of arrived
at these different approaches
to writing.
What was the first to your mind,
like the first writing piece that you did
that kind of put you on the map?
Where, not like, I've arrived,
but like, okay I actually
could make this work.
I could actually be really good at this.
Or, wow, I just got
recognition for this piece.
I mean, where there any
sort of defining moments
in your career as a writer?
- Yeah, I think, I mean, I don't know.
I mean, the things that I remember,
I remember like I was,
by the way, the best way
to get started in anything
is to to be willing to work for free.
- Yeah.
- Internships, to me,
are the path to anything.
I really think being, there's
definitely a lot of people
who are entitled, basically,
I have so much to say.
- Yeah.
- But anyway, if you want to live
in your passion,
(laughter)
whatever your passion is,
you have to be willing
to not make money at it.
If you want to do what you love,
you have a choice, you can choose money,
or you can choose what you love.
Joseph Campbell has a great
quote that I always use,
I don't know if you guys know this--
- Joseph Campbell, so the
hero with a thousand faces.
- Yeah the great professor of mythology.
But he said the, have you guys heard this?
The insecure way is the secure way.
- [Audience Member] Mhm.
- You guys have heard that quote?
And what it means basically is, you know,
my parents, and I'm sure like
most people's parents say,
get a good job, try and make
some money, make a good living.
- Yep.
- Because they think that's secure,
if you make go and make money.
But if you do a job and you make money,
and you lose that job,
- Yep.
- Then yo lose the money,
and you have nothing.
- Right, right, right.
- What he says, if you
choose your passion,
- Yeah.
- Actually doesn't matter
whether you make money
or you lose money, because
you're always going to have
your passion and be happy, so
it doesn't actually matter.
- And that's your safety net.
- Right.
But the challenge of that is
that it might be eight years
or four years before you're
actually making a living at it.
- Yep.
- Versus something else.
(slam)
- What about the business
of being what you are now?
The musician, the songwriter.
I mean, did you display and early talent
for singing?
- I didn't actually, I got
thrown out of the choir.
(audience laughing)
- [Michael] Did you?
- I was thrown out of
the choir for, I think,
as far as I know, it was for talking.
(audience laughing)
And I always remember my
dad used to say to me,
you know, because I used to say dad,
that when I was like
sixteen, seventeen, eighteen,
and my dad was threatening
to throw me out of the house
if I didn't get a job within
a certain amount of time.
So obviously I went out and got jobs,
but I was saying I want
to be a singer, you know,
I think I'm going to be rich and famous.
And he would say, you know,
"everybody wants to be a pop
singer, everybody wants,"
and sat there, and I would say, "no, Dad,
everybody wants to be a
pop singer when they're 12,
you know, when they're 12.
(audience laughing)
This is my whole life,
this is what I want to do."
But, I've lost my train of thought.
(audience laughing)
- Was it to be rich and
famous, your ambition?
I mean, was that it?
- No, I think I had two
very, very strong ambitions
and they've always fought
against one another, always.
And one was a passion for music,
and an ability to
communicate through music,
and really a sense of
purpose through music.
And two, was this desire
to be, and rich an famous
is not right, because actually
rich never came into it.
I actually realized about six months ago,
someone put a question to me,
and I actually realized that at no point
during my early life when I was,
in all my ambitions,
and even when I started
to realize my ambitions, at no
point did it ever occur to me
that one of the byproducts
of this would be
that I could buy whatever I wanted,
or you know, live in a big
house, have a flashy car,
all the things that are very
- [Michael] Yes.
- Pleasant, you know.
But it really hadn't occurred to me,
it never occurred to me.
So I didn't want to be rich,
I just wanted to be filthily famous.
(slam)
- There's a lot of work
that we're responsible for
that other people can't do, you know.
There's a saying that says,
you can lead a horse to the water,
- [Interviewer] But you can't--
- But you can't make them drink.
In the presence of common
sense and rational thinking,
even in throes of your despair,
it is your responsibility
if you are willing to still
commit to saving your own life.
To hear that, and to walk
toward that voice, you know.
So, you know, I want to recognize
personal responsibility.
And in what we try to do here today,
one of the things that makes body building
a significant vehicle for
therapy, and maybe even a tool
towards personal
development, it is just that.
You know, in order to be
able to do this effectively,
you have to recognize your
personal responsibility.
So, with that said, you know,
I want to submit to you
that the word believe,
believe is work.
You can substitute work for believe.
You know, because when I'm working,
what are you working for?
If you're working without a belief
and the idea that you're
going to get paid,
then what is your work for?
What is the purpose?
So, I believe that, you
know, to talk about believing
is to talk about being
willing to do the work.
(slam)
- Whatever you going to do,
just do it for a reason.
You know what I'm
saying, don't be the fool
that just sit back and do it
because somebody else is doing it.
Because if all that you
going to do is follow
in somebody else's footsteps,
you're just going to be a shadow.
Who wants to be a shadow
for the rest of their life,
you know what I'm saying?
If you got a little something
that you know how to do,
progress at it, keep trying,
God knows what could happen,
you know what I'm saying?
That's what I did, just kept on rapping,
just happened to get to the right areas,
you know what I'm saying?
(slam)
- Martin Luther King tried
to commit suicide twice.
You guys seen Osine here?
JFK went through periods of deep illness,
deeply, deeply ill where
people thought he would die.
These types of things, right?
Winston Churchill went through
deep, deep depressions.
So you can become one of those people,
doesn't mean you're going
to become on of them
because that's, I mean those guys
are in their own universe, but you know.
You can become somebody of great power
if you've gone through that,
because you've been hardened.
Do you guys see what I mean here?
If you've been through that kind of bull,
then if you've conditioned yourself
to pull yourself out
of something like that,
if the world gets all up,
all the other people,
they're used to happiness.
They're like, woah, happy,
and they're like, my happy
world's falling apart!
My happy world, it's falling apart!
Gets all, you're just like,
it's all good baby, hell yeah.
You know, you don't care,
because you're adjusted to it.
You've taken conscious control.
Do you guys see what I mean?
- [Audience Memmber] Mm.
- Okay?
So there's benefits.
Being a hard case newbie
means that you can be better
than any of the guys that had it easily.
It'll be harder to get,
but you can excel to a higher level
than all the people that
were naturally good,
if you choose to.
But for you, it will
be a life of commitment
in the same way that a guy
that wants to get kind of big
in the gym, if he's going
to be big in the gym
and he's a hard gainer little skinny dude,
he's going to have a
higher commitment level
to get to that level,
you're going to have a
higher commitment level,
you're not going to get
to average as easily.
And sometimes even
striving to stay at average
won't work for you because you slip back,
so you have to really commit, you have to,
you have to take your
foot off the parking brake
and you have to burn
the boats, as they say,
and just go for it.
As a hard case newbie, if you do that,
you can slowly build
those willpower muscles,
slowly re-acclimate
your body to positivity,
build up friends, build up abundance,
build an amazing situation for yourself,
do amazing, amazing things.
(slam)
- I continually learn from my mistakes
and other people's mistakes.
See, entrepreneurs think
that, hey, to create
that billion dollar company,
or hundred million dollar
company, or even million dollar company,
you have to be really smart.
And sure, brains is part of
it, luck is a huge component,
but what I've learned over the years
is everyone, no matter how smart you are,
you're going to fail many times,
you're going to make mistakes.
Just look at Mark Zuckerberg,
Facebook worked out.
His version of Snapchat that
was copy-cat did not work out.
Right?
So there's other areas
in which Facebook failed,
but Facebook overall as
a company has done great.
Just because you're smart
doesn't mean you're
always going to succeed
with everything you try or touch.
But, every time you do something,
you will learn new things,
you'll make mistakes, and if
you learn from these mistakes
and avoid making them over and over again,
you'll actually increase
your odds of succeeding
as time goes on.
And the best way to do
this is not just to learn
from your mistakes, but it's also to learn
from the mistakes of others.
Rockefeller, Carnagie, all these people
who were entrepreneurs years
ago in the 1800s, 1900s,
they themselves used business
principles and concepts
that are still applicable
in today's world.
Sure, we have the internet,
but the same strategies
and concepts they they used
are still applicable, right?
So learn from their mistakes,
learn what worked for them,
what didn't work for them
and why, and bring that into
what you're doing today.
(slam)
(dramatic music)
- In the very beginning of
me getting into the industry,
I would, you know, be out and about,
and I would hear girls, or actresses,
or musicians, or whatever, you know,
they would say, oh no I don't
want to be in a relationship
because I don't want to have to choose
between being in a relationship
and having a career.
And I thought to myself, pfft,
well when I get to know that,
when I find that person that's
going to be my, you know,
life partner, I won't ever have to choose,
because they'll be accepting of me
completely for who I am.
Not me being able to just
like do whatever I want
necessarily, but they won't be threatened
or have weird motives, or whatever.
They will be accepting
of me, the things I love,
the ambition, what I aspire to be,
what I want to create, they'll
be accepting and supportive.
And then I started to realize,
oh my God, that's not true.
Like that fairytale that I had
is not true for me right now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
but you still miss him.
- Yeah (sighing).
I don't want...
(slow music)
- [Announcer] Okay again
everyone, gates are closed,
gates are closed (drowned out by music).
- I'll tell you the truth (sniffing),
is, I mean, I'm a romantic,
and I kind of believed in this fairytale.
(sniffing)
I mean (sighs), and in some ways,
I think that's always
been to my advantage,
because like, if you can
believe in something great,
I feel like you can
achieve something great.
(footsteps)
I have that same belief
system with everything
from career to my life, my
personal life, everything.
And I will do everything
it takes to not fail,
and I did everything it
took, but it still failed.
- [Announcer] 321.
(slow music)
- The bad that comes along
with the good is a journey
and I learned so much from that journey.
(slam)
- I mean, you are
unforgivingly who you are.
Have you always been like that?
- No, no.
- [Interviewer] What happened?
- Like when I was in college.
- [Interviewer] What were you like,
like were you ever insecure?
- I still am insecure, like, I mean,
there's probably people
snickering backstage
right now at that question, like (laughs).
(audience laughing)
When I was in college I
didn't want to come out
as a progressive because I would eliminate
like half of my future
employers in Washington D.C.
I was like, look, I got
to look neutral here
so I can get a job someday.
I found, progressively, and you know,
some of these lessons were forced upon me.
I mentioned earlier, so
not to repeat a story,
I was at Google, I am working on this team
and this wireless stuff.
It was incredible, my responsibility.
Larry had given me, Larry
Page had given me billions
of dollars to go take on
the wireless carriers,
and I was in over my head.
I didn't have a background in this stuff,
and I was leaning fast,
and I was pretty good at it
but one day a decision came up
and I didn't know what to do,
and my work partner wrote in the notes,
"Chris doesn't know
what to do about this."
And at Google, the notes are
published to the whole company.
So, I see the notes get
published, and I'm like,
"what did you do, you
just ruined my career!
Everyone's going to know,
like, I'm smoke and mirrors."
And I thought it was over for me.
And then the next meeting,
some new engineers
who didn't report to me,
and Larry Page himself
showed up with ideas on what
to do to solve this problem,
and I was like, oh my God,
I just became more powerful.
I now have influence.
I have more bodies working for me
who don't even report to me.
I mean, I wish I could say
it was an enlightened choice
I'd made, it was totally forced upon me
and I was angry about it, but it worked.
(laughter)
And so, along the way I realized
that the candor, the
authenticity, the vulnerability,
is what actually attracts
the other people to you.
The insecurity roots you in this place
of showing you're impervious
that you've got all the answers
but what that does is it
renders everyone around you
helpless, they're just like,
I'm not valued here, right?
And when you start to admit that, like,
I don't know what I'm
doing, I need some help,
then people start attracting
you and working with you.
I mean, I have a principle
that I guide my life by
and try and teach this
to our entrepreneurs
called bold humility.
There are all these
business books that say,
like, hey, be humble,
be humble, by humble.
But humility is not a natural state
for a kick-ass human being, right?
If you're here, you
probably kick a lot of ass
at something, you're probably
the best at something.
You have ambition, you're a risk taker,
you have learned to hack,
you are a good talker,
you have through the gift of gab
wound your way into an amazing situation.
You hustle, hustle, hustle.
And I feel like it's unnatural
to apologize for that.
But where we get into trouble,
is when we feel like
we have to extend that
to the shit we don't know.
When we have to feel like
we've got it all covered.
And so, I think I have
had such a great, like,
I don't know if I would've
learned this authenticity
if I didn't have Twitter, and the replies
being like, that means a lot
to me, go for it, you know.
And that's why I kind of live
a lot of my life in public.
Because I feel I draw a lot of strength
and reassurance from
the public being like,
look that moment of
failure meant a lot to me
and I identify with it.
(slam)
- Tyler for you, you've got
a deal on Cartoon Network
that's Time Warner, you've
got a deal with Sony,
you've used this apparatus,
even though you're only 23,
you've used this existing
system to build up your profile.
Do you think you could start
literally without any
of this support system
and create yourself?
- Yeah, of course.
Because that's how I started, like,
the way that I got famous
was me going on Tumblr
and creating my own website,
and just putting things out
like that with the strategic,
you know, it had a strategy to it,
but putting out music for free,
and that's how it got known,
and next thing I know, Sony's like, hey,
we'll give you a bunch of money
to do an ex and oh, and
we just eat a little bit
and I've used them to my advantage
in the same way that
I've used other things,
you know, to my advantage.
- [Interviewer] They didn't make you?
- No, not at all.
You know, so I know how to
do this without, you know,
those platforms.
And another thing is, the
fun thing about this is,
I'm not, we in our squad,
we're not afraid to fail.
Like, we're not scared of
failing or whatever, so
we're learning as we go.
So maybe this doesn't work out,
but it'll be a learning experience
and that'll help other people
look at the mistakes we made
and figure out what they're trying to do.
(whoosh)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of the video?
Did you enjoy it?
Are you motivated?
Did you learn something from it?
What was your favorite clip?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I'm also curious to figure out,
should this series continue or not?
It's one of our bubble series right now,
maybe we'll keep going,
maybe we won't, we'll see.
So your comments will make a difference.
Leave it down and let me know either way.
If you hate it, that's good, too.
Let me know, leave it in the comments.
Finally want to give a quick
shout out to Rebecca Coleman.
Rebecca thank you so much
for picking up the ebook
version of Your One Word.
I really appreciate you buying it
and also Tweeting it
out with that picture.
I hope you enjoy that glass
of wine as well, as you read.
Thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(rumbling)